إنها الخامسة والنصف صباحًا هنا في
المطار ومع حوالي 75
صحفيًا آخر ، ننتظر للتو
ركوب الطائرة البابوية إلى بغداد
في المرة الأولى التي يسافر فيها بابا إلى
العراق ، إنها رحلة تاريخية.
العراق بلد يغلب عليه المسلمون
ولكن مع
مجتمع مسيحي قديم مهم ،
وهو مجتمع تضاءل
بشكل كبير
في العقود الماضية ،
سيظهر البابا دعمه لهذا
المجتمع ولجميع الناس في العراق
، أطلق الفاتيكان على
هذه الرحلة بادرة حب
نحن على متنها الآن  فقط في انتظار
وصول البابا فرانسيس ،
ستلاحظ أن الجميع
يرتدون أقنعة على الرغم من أننا لسنا
بعيدين اجتماعيًا بشكل خاص
ولكننا جميعًا تم تطعيم البابا
فرانسيس أيضًا
مع أحد الأسئلة الكبيرة
التي ستطرح في هذه الرحلة سواء كانت كذلك
من الحكمة حقًا أن يسافر البابا فرانسيس
إلى العراق أثناء الوباء
لأننا جميعًا مُلقحين ولكن ليس كل
العراقيين صعبًا
إذا خرج القارب ، فالكثير من
الناس يذهبون  يرغب في المجيء ورؤيته
ويمكن أن يشكل خطرًا حقيقيًا على صحة
العراقيين ،
فهو يشعر أن هذا واجب عليه أن
يفي بالالتزام الذي قطعه على نفسه
من الكنيسة
والسلطات
السياسية ويريد أن ينجز تلك المهمة التي
وعد
حتى عاد البابا وقال
أين يجلس الصحفيون ليقولوا مرحبًا ، إنه
تقليد
في رحلات أبريل عادةً ما يصافحنا
لن يفعل ذلك
الآن من أجل فيروس كورونا ولكن الناس أحيانًا
يعطونه كتبًا أو يقولوا مرحبًا فقط
غير مسموح به حقًا  اطرح عليهم أسئلة
في هذا الوقت
وها نحن خارج طائرة البابا
في بغداد ، إنها حقًا
لحظة مؤثرة مثيرة يجب أن أقولها هنا على
مدرج المطار في الحقيبة التي جاء بها
البابا فرانسيس إلى هذه الأمة التي
شهدت
الكثير خلال العقد الماضي
وها هو أول بابا تطأ قدمه
أرض العراق على الإطلاق